hi there
steve here to talk about language
learning my 90-day challenge continues
and uh but today i want to talk about
talent and language learning
and a few other things around mood and
language learning so there are lots of
negative news there's many people are
very pessimistic about the world you
know that we're going to destroy the
planet i'm not i'm very optimistic
uh there's a lot of negativity around
the election in the united states and so
on and so on
uh which i share to some extent but hey
we won't have to wait and see but anyway
on the tv is this um
tennis tournament it's the ladies i
think it's the federation cup
and the czechs the czech girls went it
for the fifth time in i don't know six
seven years
but what struck me what was amazing
other than the fact that it was between
france and uh czech republic it was an
excellent uh game of doubles i only saw
a bit of the doubles game all four girls
were excellent tennis players it's fun
to watch people who excel in something
and then they interviewed the winners
the checks
two czech girls and the czech coach and
they spoke english so
well and i'm always in awe of people who
speak another language well
and then it reminded me that generally
speaking athletes
speak english well because you see them
interviewed
i've mentioned this before hockey
players in north america whether russian
or czech or swedish were finished
they all speak english very very well
very often if you get a foreign-born
professor or teacher's assistant at
university their english is not very
good
um
so is it that hockey players or athletes
in general tennis players have a special
talent for learning languages they have
a special gene that comes from being
athletes i don't think so
i think it is a matter of to them it's
normal it's something that's expected
they spend a lot of time with their
fellow athletes whether it be teammates
or in the case of the tennis players
they all know each other on the circuit
you know and it reminds me of that time
when
there was a bit of a controversy because
the the u.s ladies professional golf
association said that that the korean
girls who were doing very well winning
lots of tournaments should really try
harder to speak english so that when
they're interviewed or when they play in
these pro-am tournaments that they can
speak english and so there was the usual
oh this is racist this is unfair this
isn't so i'm saying what are you talking
about they make their living
playing golf
uh people sponsor
uh
yeah there might be tv action in korea
but there's a huge market in north
america learn english it's that simple
and you know what today most those girls
speak very good english whether they're
korean thai there's so many good asian
golfers on the uh ladies golf tournament
circuit chinese you name it and they all
speak english very very well
so i don't think athletes have a special
talent for language learning i think
it's a matter of attitude mood we're
just going to do it it's no big deal
and
they managed to speak
so i had a few other things but i'm
going to save them for
another occasion oh the other one thing
i wanted to say was you know language
learning is about emotion it's about
context and now that i'm back at our
place here in palm springs
somehow i think i should be learning
polish because my sort of emotional
connection was when i was last here i
was going through my polish challenge
and i was riding on my you know my bike
and i was eating even hitting golf balls
at the range listening to polish somehow
this is my polish space but now it's not
it's my korean space so there you have
it thanks for listening bye for now